welcome back i couldn't begin this
journey without two women who have been
a part of my heart for over 20 years
we are friends we are fellow angels
please welcome my partners in crime and
life lucy liu
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
first i sent cameron a video
and i'm saying hey listen i got it like
i want to ask you something
will you come on the show um which
i mean i've never done this in my life
because i'm so comfortable i mean we
have
lived together all over the world so of
course
to save time i sent her a video while
i'm getting dressed
and you don't see anything i'm not that
dumb
but i'm getting out of the shower and
i'm like ringing out of my towel
and i don't hear back from her for like
two days and i'm like this is weird
did i what is going on so i text her and
i'm like i don't care
about the question are you okay i don't
hear again for two days i'm freaking out
so i call her and i'm like what is going
on i'm worried
is everything okay she's like i don't
know what you're talking about i'm like
the video
you didn't get my video turns out
a young boy watched the video
lucky him oh no
oh no by the way it's like seven minutes
long
oh my gosh there it is
it's like epic i mean this is some
material secrets
material for like honestly he can use
this is gonna last him three or four
years
i mean i you know i'm really like
hamming it up because it's
you know because it's you yeah it was
good i was like send me that video
immediately i need to know what is in
that video and
the whole while i'm just like cracking
up
because you need to send me this video
as well or do it through someone else
because i didn't get your other video
either so then someone's like did you
get her videos like no
no i'm something's wrong with my phone
so i sent lucy this video
crying inviting her on the show saying
in her bathroom crying i am in my bag
she was dressed
i was fully clothed this time i didn't
take the risk
and she didn't get the video either come
on
i know i know you uh the thing that i
love
about our friendship is that we have
been there
in all the big and important moments
we've also been there
in the small moments and the casual
moments
and the reason we are such good friends
is because it's
real and we go through real stuff with
each other
it's not a hollywood fairy tale
[Music]
you